well sup tenza I once met Denzel
Washington at a carnival the st. Charles
Festival and I didn't know who he was I
didn't recognize him at the time you
know like the only thing I had known
Denzel Washington from when I was at
this age which was like four or five was
virtuosity I had seen no other Denzel
movies at that point and my brother was
aware this was Denzel Washington but he
told me to go up to him and say are you
the dad from family members my brother
was kind of a dick so I bullied me so I
was like ah [ __ ] him I'm just gonna go
up to this guy and say it years I don't
think it's him but I didn't I thought it
was just some random dude I didn't
realize it was Denzel Washington as an
asked him are you the dad from family
matters and he he smiled and said no
there's really no interesting end to
this story let's watch this
the Magnificent Seven official teaser
trailer number one anton fuqua i think
that's how you say his name he directed
this and you know he's got his man
denzel in their training day equalizer
now magnificent seven lot of people
really against the fact that good
because it's a remake if we're gonna get
remakes it's at the point now where I'm
like well yeah I could see how they
could remake that and they don't have a
they can do that with the Magnificent
Seven man are gonna update that action
dear Village Roadshow
sir I have a proposition work they sent
people being driven from our home
slaughtered in cold blood yeah
[Music]
impossible oh damn you got so far
you and me
dobry okkadine hiking quite a batchest
race this is not going to end will
oh good high-speed this rides Agility's
yeah man I give a [ __ ] that it's
remaking this really cool IMAX you're
gonna get to see that in IMAX
the movie that introduced me to this
director you know he's done a lot of
films the you know that he's done by
King Arthur he's done that
Brooklyn something tears of the Sun
training day the equalizer but the first
movie I ever saw of Anton fuqua was the
replacement chillers with Shao Yin fat
and Mira Sorvino and that movie was a
badass gun flick that movie was a bad
ass Ville and to this day I like he's
never captured cool action like that
ever since life like replacement killers
was like yeah that's when he captured
action at its best at least I think it's
been a few years I know I know how he
knows how to make like gun action look
cool and I have been really thinking
like damn they could do a Western
I know Tarantino's like cover in western
ground a lot lately and you know there's
like bone tomahawk there's some great
westerns that still come out and I
encourage you people to watch westerns
and although this looks like a little
you know Hollywood it up I don't mind it
I mean it's got an awesome cast him to
toll they love to watch Denzel is he
Denzel is so cool
like he walks it's like if you like type
in on Google most attractive qualities
in a man you find a list Denzel is all
those things just in his walk Chris
Pratt man first thing I saw him it was
five-year engagement and and and and
Parks and Rec like he's the last dude I
expected to be like this [ __ ] action
[ __ ] but no it's cool to see him doing
like a supporting role if this was led
by Chris Pratt I'd probably be bothered
by it it makes it a lot cooler he's in a
supporting part and Ethan Hawke you know
I do
even hock does a lot of movies that are
great that no one ever watched this MN
and Vincent D'Onofrio got poopy I am DP
on this [ __ ] I gotta know my facts right
now the Magnificent Seven
that's who a Bennett okay know why
couldn't pinpoint who it was
oh that's cool Haley been a good good
for you good for you Haley Bennett I
feel like I've seen you hardcore Henry
that's right dude you just climbing up
that action ladder oh do you Pete okay
if there was a period in my life where
you know when people asked what after do
you hate it was really like easy for me
to answer that and that actor was Peter
Sarsgaard I thought like for some reason
this guy is getting all these roles he's
just kind of like how people feel about
Jai Courtney but even less emotional you
know he doesn't really bother me now
just something about him that kind of
gets on my nerves
he said what's the play a villain is
this Vinnie Joneses and this was even
the trailer did I miss that
hell yeah man Vee Jones snatch Lock
Stock and oh there's no way I'm gonna
pronounce this guy's name like ever
the guy from GI Joe and and he played a
the Terminator and I the t1000 in
Terminator Genisys by by young Hundley
hopefully I got that right I know we
have a very large China base audience so
you two even allowed over there actually
I remember there was like a country I'm
banned from here's what I want from this
movie all right I watched the
Magnificent Seven one time with my dad
when I was really young don't remember
it at that age I did not appreciate
Western so it was until I was like I
came across Steve McQueen's Nevada Smith
and that kind of just changed my
perspective
Planck whenever a Western is just like
actually defined well so I feel like we
got this group of like seven characters
who are gonna all have cool
personalities cuz they're brought to you
by actors who even if they got crappy
scripts they would you know bring
something more to the role regardless
and with anton fuqua i remember man
replaced me killers this guy knows how
to direct this grabbing it and Denzel
clearly likes him you know sounds like
they're buddies wish I could be part of
that group yeah so I want some badass
leads and some badass action I feel like
we got it I feel like this is that movie
we could remake like every 20 years
there should be the last time what's the
Magnificent 7 already a remake anyway
guys this video is done if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe today and
become a reject yeah become a reject you
can follow me on facebook instagram and
twitter at the greg alba and at the real
rejects i want to give a shout out to
the kids who are always outside my
window kids if you're watching this i
love you
you guys are awesome seriously you're
all you're all really cool kids you know
like it's i it's very sweet i know in
the past videos i've like bagged on you
but now in all honesty like i do feel
like a genuine smile come to my face
whenever i see you guys outside and like
it's cool to have you all the supporters
and i'm sure you kids love watching you
know western movies and so i'm sure you
caught this video